so Wow so you'll know yeah you know what
I don't think I would ever quit - you
know how much fun is that this fun it's
a nurse a miserable misery involved
really what's your misery damn it
well he did okay I forgive him
why nothing what's your hurt my heart is
this is that I get like I get resentful
quick like the other night I think it
was last night
Ali Wong brought me up I give pretty
good intros you give great intro you
might not right though be real and what
do i you yeah you really do because I
get specific yeah and you tell a story
tell a story you tell the story about
what you just said about me meeting me
on the gamblin and all that stuff yeah
yeah now the only thing and I tried to
catch you the other night and now maybe
we can have this discussion when I go up
around town I don't
I hate credits so I always go up as
Larry Smith from as from Fresno I know
you do I know you do I hate credits I
don't even like my name so we're at the
improv we're at the improv and I
remember the host coming up to you and
go Larry Smith again yeah and you go
yeah Fresno yeah
so he goes Larry Smith from Fresno and
then you went up why is that so as
beautiful as your and I I admire and
thank you for your very respectful and
beautiful intro yeah but in the future
since we're talking about it what you
tell me before yeah I was going to but
you yeah I didn't have a chance
no but I've been bringing you up for the
last year I brought you a 40 [ __ ]
time but now I'm hearing about the Larry
Smith from [ __ ] intro [ __ ]
[ __ ] but you're you know it was
signed on you see I mean I've talked to
you before that we've I've been your
house in that [ __ ] I know but now it
comes out I know I guess now this is why
this is fate
excuse me smoothing yes guy-guy if you
have any kind of resentment or thing
that that you have toward me yeah I
would hope that you would just express
yourself then I feel like this Larry
summit thing is something that you've
been hiding no no there's no resentment
at all no it's just it's just a
something I'm just telling you the
freaking forgive me oh yeah no no no
resentment no animosity nothing ask your
wife she knows but I want an intro you
want an intro yeah right you won't have
when Ali brought me up date last night
this guy yeah Bobby Lee that's it yeah
and I yeah it's like one of my intro I
know
and I sat there and went up it's fine I
love her
mm-hmm but I don't know why I get so
[ __ ] weird out by that yeah excuse me
it hurts yeah it what what I want to
know what is it about me that's been oh
do you feel it's not respectful it's a
lack of respect
it's not even credits though it's it
that's not about credit it's about you
know when I bring somebody on it's like
oh here's my friend you guys like me
right
this is basically you guys like to me
and even if you're a lot of you are my
fans I would like you to introduce you
to my friend who's just as good or
better please enjoy
and her answer was just kind of a throw
alike as if you know we kind of know
each other but you don't but I know her
right he's you know who else does a lot
of people do that you know anyway stand
up what that's the hurt in stand up they
say you take things you want people to
give you the same praise you give them
[Music]